yes I know there's a new episode of the
wolf among us and the walking dead
season 2 but new mariokart came out I
got to talk about that although I
will talk about wolf among us and
Walking Dead I will Mario Kart 8 so
Mario Kart 8 is the 8th Mario Kart in
the Mario Kart series these Mario Kart
games are good they like the definitive
battle kart racing game the urban Mario
Kart clones out there some of them have
actually been good but Mario Kart is the
one they're like you all tried to be me
at this point the 8th Mario Kart is
there really anything new that they can
offer in the Mario Kart series you look
at Smash Brothers 3 exists in total
fourth ones on the way Mario Kart has 8
so at this point I'm like what can it
have fairly I can still have a lot of
fun first of all the game looks great
it's a Nintendo brand Nintendo game on a
Nintendo system those always look right
they always play great you get right
into vision like this looks live and the
colors are really good then you start
racing you're like that's a lot of fun
this iconic Mario Kart you push
your gas pedal at the right time you're
gonna have a little boost at the
beginning oh look at that I got an item
oh it's coins alright just wait another
item banana
alright cool nah girl I 50cc is actually
kind of boring to 100cc and up that's
what it starts getting fun well I look
to my friend at a point I was like the
level designs are really good all the
levels in this game are really cool you
can actually do a thing where you can go
on the walls I mean the tracks just go
all over the place but when you're kind
of in a third person and it's locked
onto a cart and the tracks just coming
out you have to look at the background
to actually notice that oh wow I'm kind
of suspended in the air or I'm upside
down conceptually you know it happens
but it doesn't like alter your
perception of the game until you go on
the wall but sometimes you're on the
wall and it feels like you're actually
sideways on the wall and that's actually
really cool when you can feel like
you're defying gravity that's when the
game actually starts you know becoming
relevant and the fact that you can defy
gravity one of the levels you're going
through an airport I was like to have
airports and the Mushroom Kingdom I
guess and you could write karts through
its pre 9/11 Mushroom Kingdom and there
a lot of unlockables the game has 30
characters but in the plethora of Mario
characters you're like where's works in
fact where are a lot of guys from Mario
- yeah shy guys always get their day in
the Sun but where is anybody else the
game did happen right so why is it like
try Clyde on his little car that is
neither here nor there with all those
characters and a lot of cars and a lot
of wheels and a lot of aw can really
it's really customizable I like the fact
that it's not just like oh that one
character and he's a little different in
that character he's a little difference
like no that character with that cart is
different as well as that character with
that cart in those wheels that's
different play Mario Kart how you want
to play it that's the point of it really
the game does this part to even out the
score for you to I have heard whispers
only whispers that little sound box
thing I used it once it's like blasted
everyone around me I'll say oh that's me
but I guess it can totally negate the
blue shell yeah that stupid blue shell
here comes up a broom you're like oh
it's not good to be the King goes after
the guy right in first place and then
smashes him in the head I guess you can
hit that box just boom he's be like ah
you blue shell come here
please don't teabag the blue shell throw
it away again I've not seen that
happening I'm in first place I get
bananas and coins and that's what I get
but that is not to say the game is not
still cheap that was doing my thing a
red shell hit me just BAM and then green
shell BAM and another green shell BAM
just like that I was like you guys are
wasting your ammo on a guy who just got
hit who's now in fifth place they're not
gonna saver for the guy who's in 4th 3rd
2nd or 1st that makes no sense
human beings wouldn't do that just
so the computers just being a dick so
yeah the computers still cheap but I'm
glad you can nerf that blue shell
because that's pretty sweet and I like
the fact that they have nostalgic levels
from other Mario Kart games in this game
but not only that those levels that
they've had from previous Mario Kart
games that are in this game have Mario
Kart 8 mechanics in it you can drive on
the walls like you can in this game and
some of the tracks go upside down you
recognize the level from the other Mario
Kart games you recognize the music from
the other Mario Kart games but the fact
that they implement these Mario Kart 8
mechanics in it it makes it feel new and
I actually like that and yeah the rumors
are true of all the rainbow roads that
they could have had from the previous
Mario Kart games they have the n64
version the level the kart track that
ruins so many friendships that might as
well be called the risk of video game
racing but they did what this one is
they divided the entire track into
ultimately three sections so you go and
then you pass section one it's like
alright now as your second Lam right now
it's your third lap so really it's one
third as long so it's kind of more
bearable I'm bummed out they don't have
more Super Nintendo tracks because that
let's face it that's the goal
right there that's where a lot of us got
our mariokart start we're like Super NES
eight characters one thing I don't like
though is that tricky wood do you know
you get a green shell then you hold down
the button and the green shells behind
you so you cover your ass with the green
shells so someone doesn't slam a red
shell up it but then it frees up your
item box you can get another item Mario
Kart 8 no until you release that button
and throw that green show you can have
it behind you guarding your ass it's
still in your item box you don't get
another item I like the fact that I
could just play the system like that
previous Mario Kart games now that it's
gone it's like an element of my strategy
and tactics are missing one thing that
just sucks ass is battle mode I like
battle mode to feel like you're in
arenas you know with objects around you
so you have to maneuver through room but
it feels like an arena feels like battle
this one battle mode ultimately feels
like a track with no clear direction as
to where to go it feels like you're
racing but you're not really racing
you're just like battling people you go
around the track until you pass
something you both throw your shell and
maybe you hit him maybe in minutes you
go back around you throw your I
mean it's actually quite boring my
friend and I played a couple rounds of
that I was like alright done let's get
back to racing but racing is really fun
so Mario Kart 8 has a lot of characters
a lot of customization it has great
level design great tracks it's fast
paced it's fun to play with friends you
do versus you do GP battle mode really
doesn't matter I like the new items in
the game it's really annoying when
you're in first place you're like coins
and bananas again still there's a lot to
love about this game there's a couple
things that are just irritating I will
say Mario Kart 8 is worth buying at full
price especially since right now I
believe until the end of the month you
can download Wind Waker for free if you
buy this like Wind Waker Pikmin 3 and a
couple other things but the fact that I
didn't have Wind Waker HD and I wanted
Wind Waker HD and now I have it for free
cuz it but Mario Kart just seems like a
steal for me I see your favorite Mario
Kart game of all time what is it
whatever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]